and you did baby driver with Spacey er
then all this stuff happens obviously
there's no signs when that's happening
but do you look back oh yeah that was a
little help man I remember being on that
set I remember him really rubbing me the
wrong way
you don't and I and and I it's funny
anybody who you know I I was working
with at the time and people in my life
remember me saying it a lot of people
reached out to me you know when that
happened and I think for me you got to
understand you know I started out in
this in this thing you know I was a
theatre actor and when I was a young man
I got to go to London and was a crazy
opportunity for me and the first thing
that I did when I was in London I went
and saw the Iceman Cometh starring Kevin
Spacey you know four and a half hour
play with him right there and I was
sitting in the front row looking with my
neck straight up and I remember when
that play was over I just jumped up and
gave a standing ovation which is
something I guess they don't [ __ ] do
in London or something because he looked
right at me and he he it was an
unbelievably sort of like transformative
experience in my life watching what he
did and he used one of my favorite
actors you know going on to that set you
know and and and and and working with
him I wasn't there much and I wasn't
really in a situation to judge but when
I was there he really rubbed me the
wrong way I I thought he was a bit of a
bully I thought he was I thought that he
I didn't really care for the way he was
behaving toward some of the other people
and said and sexually or aggressive I
think I think a combination I think a
combination I think he was he was uh you
know I think he was you know acting
towards people in a way that I remember
at the time thinking man if that was if
that was a woman that he was talking to
you know I would I would have I would
have done something I would have said
something and I was really happy to sort
of get out of there and and and and I
remember you know for it for that reason
and I just remember losing a ton of
respect for him and nowhere did I see
anything like some of the allegations
that have come up against him and I
think it's it would be weak and and me
and of me just sort of like pile on
about some [ __ ] that I don't know about
right but the kind of man he was when I
saw him working with him made me lose
all respect for him and I was enormous
ly disappointed it kind of is amazing
the
that like in the last year all these big
projects that you're doing end up
somehow getting attached to these big
other stories stories yeah you know look
man it's tough because you know right
now everybody's got a voice and and and
it's so easy to sort of manure voice
heard there's great things about that
and there's negative parts about it as
well you know and the fact of the matter
is if you behave like a monster
you know I nowadays like you're gonna
get called out for that [ __ ] and and you
should and you [ __ ] [ __ ] man and and
like times need to change with that
stuff and and and you know it's like
look man there's one thing in the world
I [ __ ] hate it's a bully and and and
I think that you know people have been
getting away with a [ __ ] for too long
it's funny we were just talking about it
before I did Howard this morning and you
know we were talking about in the green
room about different people and like
everyone's so scared and you know
somebody made a really good comment like
the people were scared probably have
good [ __ ] reason to be scared you
know and and you you know I I think that
I thought I think I think the thing that
we have to watch for is it's an industry
where people want to bring attention to
themselves you know I mean and so I
think that we've got to be you you know
I think that we've got to just be IIIi
think we've just got to be hesitant
again and this is why I'm a little bit
hesitant like when you asked me about
Spacey you know like I don't want to
pile on sure a pile on that's what I saw
that's how it affected me and that's
that's what I do okay I think I I like
the you don't I like because you came to
only speaking about what you've seen and
because people how could all this stuff
go unnoticed or untalked about but on
what is the dynamic on a set when
there's a a star and the star is a
little difficult to like you said maybe
a little bit bullying and no one's gonna
walk up and go hey shut the [ __ ] up
you're being what is the dynamic of that
when the star is being difficult or a
bully to people you know man
you know like for everything is
different and and and and you know look
at the end of the day you know you it's
an artistic endeavor right it's it's
it's it's you're there to make something
you know you're there to make something
and every director has a different
method and every director let's the the
atmosphere the set sort of go in many
different ways and I have been in
situations where I think that if you
looked at what we were actually doing
right then if you looked at what the
cast and the crew were doing on set
you'd be like home
[ __ ] this is dangerous this is chaotic
this is unsavory you know but it's
exactly essential what we needed to make
the moment that we were making right you
know if you if you looked at the the
orgy scenes in in wolf of Wall Street
you know I I'm sure that you know if you
just looked at that in a bubble you'd be
like what the [ __ ] were those guys it
was crazy experience but that's what we
needed to do that being said there was
no disrespect
everybody everybody treated each other
professionally everybody you know there
was zero tolerance for people sort of
lording power over other people and you
know III think that I really do think
that those days of that kind of behavior
are going to end because of all this I
really do think yeah I think you're
right did anyone warn you like about
space here was there kind of word out
there that he's kind of a creep or he's
an [ __ ] I heard I mean not really I
mean I I had heard stories you know I I
had heard stories but you know to me
it's like you know I'm there to go do a
job yeah I mean I'm there to go do a job
and and and like you know man I'm not
gonna [ __ ] you I walked onto that
set and I'm just like I got immense
respect for this guy he's one of my
favorite actors you know he's yeah
enormous ly talented so that's what I
walked in with and you know it didn't
take a long time for me how long until
he like it didn't take me long it's
weird because you almost do when someone
is that good at something you almost
don't want to believe it you know
there's like a partier but I mean I had
a certain point it becomes undeniable I
guess I think the majority of the people
that I've gotten to work with and meet
in this profession like they're good
people they're good they're confident
they're solid people I think that you
know to be good at this thing like it
takes a level of empathy where you're
open to people you don't judge them for
you know their race or religion their
sexual orientation you celebrate the
differences in people I think that's all
sort of like part of the the gig and and
if you're not innately that way I don't
think you're going to be a great actor
you know and and so the majority of the
people I meet who are who are great
people that I really admire have turned
out to be great people in real life too
and and you know when I think about De
Niro or
DiCaprio or Brad Pitt you know these
these guys are heroes of mine then I go
and meet him work with him and I only
love them more does that make it like
inexcusable when you see it happening
like when you meet a guy like Scorsese
did you get along with Scorsese he's the
best so when you meet Scorsese right and
you're like that's an awesome dude
is it almost like if that dude can be an
awesome dude anybody nobody nobody's got
me yeah yeah and-and-and and look there
I think that there's a you know somebody
like me there I come in with a level of
reverence and respect you know these
guys had like enormous if it you know
Scorsese man yeah had enormous effect on
my life you know he's shaped so much of
what I feel what I do what I care about
and so you go in but you know there's
you know anytime somebody comes towards
you with respect
you got wanted to you got what it's only
you go one way or the other right you
can either [ __ ] on that person and treat
them like dirt or you can you you can
welcome them in it's it's one way or the
other and and to me you know most people
who are confident and and and successful
and and have some level of peace of mind
you know and and and for the most part I
think that if you're really good at
something you don't have it's like you
you've given all that other [ __ ] up you
don't have to lord over somebody who's
in a less powerful position